hi guys it's Silva Rhett again and I got
some feedback on my lights place some
people were like do more do more time
lapses and other people were like no
don't do more time lapses you need to
talk a bit more so I figured I need to
get the balance right so I'm just going
to do do a little bit of commentary can
lie about what I'm going to do with this
park for example because I've got a
small idea that I got from flux trance
actually it's yeah it's a once again
it's it's flux runs and basically I was
watching his stream finally because I I
was always trying to catch up a stream
but the thing is he's in America and I'm
in Holland and time zones aren't really
great and he always streams late at
night but usually I'm asleep at that
point it's only in the morning for me
and I don't usually wake up that early
so woke up early today and softlocks
runs a stream and he was doing his
endorsed industrial stuff building loads
of pipes and I was like hmm maybe I can
use those pipes in my parks well and he
was just like yeah you should actually
so yeah I'm probably going to take a
more industrial take on this scene on
this theme from now on but that's all
later on because for now I thought I
finished this hopper ride but apparently
I haven't really done anything to the
theming yet I think I did but then the
park crashed or something like that
so I'm just picking this up again but I
also want to theme it a bit more heavily
than I originally wanted to so I'm going
to and a little building in here or
something like that and also I have got
the idea to just place industrial slash
steampunk Alpine buildings all over the
place right here that may sound like a
totally crazy idea but I just hope that
it's going to work out somehow because
if it worked if it would work out then
it's going to be a totally original and
unique thing I guess so that would be
kind of cool but for now I'm just going
to use these wooden railings just to get
that medieval part of it done then the
walls are probably going to be
industrial / steampunk and I might
actually add some copper pipes I mean
I've worked on copper pipes in my
steampunk set but they didn't quite look
great but then I figured I could also
just use the SMAW
says Industrial theming set for the
pipes and just give it a copper color
and hope that it's going to look good so
that's the plan from now on planner I
kind of have because I have no clue what
this is going to look like I'm just
going to build mine spur-of-the-moment
just see what out whenever I can come up
with and hope that it's going to be
something good I figured that the lake
site needs to have fences and stuff and
just simple brick walls or something
like that maybe some industrial stuff
going on but this side maybe have a
little gallery of some sorts maybe it's
not my steampunk set because people all
kept actually asking for pieces of the
set but the thing is it's it's it's an
unfinished sat with steampunk steampunk
pieces so yeah you can't get that just
yet I know I should release this but I
really suck at releasing custom scenery
I've made so many sets and I haven't
released any of them yet though I'm
currently working on a Rome Roman themed
set with pieces that you can rebuild the
ancient Roman marketplace with and
that's probably going to be finished
because it's a school project and I'm
actually almost done with it it's just
how people keep requesting pieces so I
just feel like I need to do all the
pieces that people request because
otherwise you know I feel like I'm
ignoring them and it's always great when
people one want you to do pieces and you
can make them and you can actually help
people with that your custom scenery but
anyway as you can see these this box
pipe is just kind of weird I mean it
could work on a big factory but I don't
exactly have big factories going on same
goes for this this glass tower kind of
thing
kind of kind of cool might this is not
the good one I think the hexagon Tower
is the better one yeah this one isn't
that bad it's pretty cool actually I
guess where's the top of that it's in
the spire you know I kind of like this
one but it doesn't exactly fit into my
park just yet though I think I can
somehow feature this at the top of one
of these hills but I'll do that later on
and then I've got some copper pipes
going on in this set but they're not
quite as good as the copper pipes
those Nazis say so I just want to see if
I can actually use those things because
that that would be great I am probably
going to use the brick walls in the set
though because they kind of fit the
entire steampunk idea now I'm pretty
sure that our pipe should be in
additions I could use the brick walls in
this set but they're not quite as aged
and medieval like well these don't quite
have the same coppery feel to it but
actually works out pretty well you know
I'm going to experiment with that a
little later but first I just want to
get this part done so open my set again
see not the war base that's war yeah mmm
I think this should work out no clipping
so that's great
mmm though it does look a bit weird in a
way then again I don't think it doesn't
fit with the rest of the park
plus I'm going to add more of this
steampunky stuff to the other part of
the park as in this park because
otherwise this part of the park because
otherwise it's going to look too much
like this and I want this castle theme
to be just right here and a castle here
and probably a castle here as well but
then this part should be finished that's
just the entrance part this coaster
should be the Alpine kind of coaster and
it's the slightly different theme right
here I mean it's the same basics but
just small details are different like
these walls that's the plan so yeah
these ones are pretty cool let's finish
this real quick right so those walls are
done and I just decided to use two
different types of walls just at random
just because you know a little bit of
variety in there it's never a bad idea
so now I feel like the edges of the dark
walls need to be light and the edges of
the light walls need to be dark I'm not
entirely sure this is going to work out
but so far it works out fine and this is
one of those zero-g things
I mean Station gym made this set for 0g
for his steampunk stuff but it works out
perfectly in any situation which is kind
of cool so I like to use this set quite
a lot now that doesn't quite work out
though all right I'm just using one on
both sides so I'm so both sides look the
same otherwise my OCD sensors are going
to be very tangled and very annoyed this
doesn't look too bad now I just don't
really know what I'm going to do with
that building for the hopper at the top
because that's going to be quite hard
and then again I need to I feel like I
need to add something to these walls
even though they're underneath a hopper
I just feel like I need to add some
windows / maybe even pipes maybe start
experimenting with that that kind of
stuff
I don't think there's anything good that
I can use in this set though these
windows to look quite good very
steampunky and they do fit these walls
so let's see about that that's actually
pretty cool I like them I might add one
underneath here you know that's not too
bad mm-hmm that looks good
you can never have enough windows always
place windows everywhere that great
though I feel like I need to add
different windows for the medieval walls
did I just oh well to the middle of
nowhere who cares and hopefully I can do
something with this iron stuff as well
like maybe even decorate the size of
these things that's pretty cool
now I don't know how I'm going to
support that yet spot I feel like
something steampunky would work and not
steampunky would work but steampunky
would work god that was terrible
mmm maybe even a cornice at the top here
this kind of fits in there yeah that's
actually pretty cool I'll do that
terraforming is a [ __ ] sometimes
as you can see it's quite annoying right
now I don't think these cornices have a
corner piece yeah that's that kind of
sucks but it's nothing I can't work with
I don't mind it too much we're not on
any corner pieces it is kind of annoying
though but just I just have to deal with
it I guess now that building on top of
it is going to be quite a challenge
let's see if there's anything in in this
that I can use maybe I can actually add
some pipes or something to this I don't
quite know that let's see are there any
good support in there I know that Larson
for support in that industry sat
somewhere no I don't need any crates
these things are very tiny yes they are
can't use those no just two small
shelves no these are all tiny hmm so I
probably need something else for that
learn oh well I can just experiment with
with the pipes already though I'm not
really good at pipes because I don't
really use them very often I'll just see
what I can do with this of course I can
add a pipe down there
oh god this is going to make it look
like Charlie and the Chocolate Factory
this is this is going to make it look
like this is a place where they make
beer in the medieval times slightly
after that oh well beer is good isn't it
now I do know that you need various
sizes and shapes of pipes in here so I'm
just going to mess with that
see that's probably a bit too much
vertical action actually going on mmm
yeah I think so I'll just do this and a
horizontal one and then I feel like I
need to add something in this space but
I don't quite know what well I'll just
do that flange is already because
otherwise I won't do them though I
should probably use a flanger down looks
a bit better
no no why I just feel like it looks
better and flanges on the side
oh my god I just realized I'm doing the
same thing as flex trans because he he
kept saying flanges as well even though
they're flying jurors but whatever I'm
too used to mobi steel jungle now this
looks like a overdose of flanges but
yeah technically I should have this many
flanges his pieces shouldn't be much
bigger and then we should probably have
like some kind of course team thing
going on but can I do that in here or is
that weird
she'd probably be a bit higher right
like that
steam effects are always cool so you
know why not and then I feel like you
know what I'm just going to do the rest
in a small time-lapse so let's speed in
the time-lapse oh but before I show that
I would like to say that I just try it's
time lapsing but it crashed so I lost
everything so if I do some [ __ ]
saving in the time-lapse then that's
because I don't want to lose too much
when it crashes okay
so that's that
to keep a straight face when I'm burning
like fire and your cold eyes
I'm drawn in desire and you have to
think twice
it's hard to keep smiling when I try to
set things straight you don't even
listen I'm just getting late you're on a
mission
whee-hee
y'all
I'm Cassie
cos it
so hard to keep smiling
when you're closing every door trying to
open I tell you love you more and you
say it's broken
you make me wait
right now at this point rollercoaster
tycoon 3 is starting to melt my computer
so I'm going to stop it right here and
continue on this next time and hopefully
I can get this building done next time
so I can do that path work on this area
right here maybe even do the station on
this coaster or add a couple of
buildings and some industrial stuff on
the coaster itself on the rock work here
so anyway thanks for watching and until
next time